bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi le taq
taq
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
mairie qu'appelle-t-on la mairie le
terme de néri désigne trois choses primo
le bâtiment où se trouvent les services
de l'administration de la commune on
parle aussi parfois d'hôtel de ville
pour les grandes communes
secundo la mairie désigne aussi
l'administration municipale et enfin la
mairie peut désigner la fonction de
maire ou de mairesses s'il s'agit d'une
femme dans le code général des
collectivités
le terme mairie désigne le siège de la
municipalité
est ce que le terme de mairie est
utilisé dans tous les pays francophones
non au canada on parlera d'hôtel de
ville pour une vie et de bureau communal
dans les autres cas en belgique on
parlera plutôt d'hôtel de ville ou de
maison communale elle sophie cattoire en
france pour une commune d'avoir une
mairie oui chaque commune doit posséder
ou louer sur son territoire quand local
ou un bâtiment faisant office de mairie
il y à quelques exceptions de communes
ayant leur mairie sur une autre commune
c'est le cas de la commune de demi
quartier dont les halles qui à sa mairie
sur la commune de megève
quelles sont les missions d'une mairie
sa mission principale est de satisfaire
les besoins de sa population
aussi la mairie à des attributions très
diverses
elle s'occupe de l'urbanisme et des
permis de construire du logement des
écoles élémentaire et maternelle des
domaines culturel sportif et des loisirs
elle entretient aussi la voirie
communale et se préoccupe de l'ordre
public local
la police municipale a pour mission de
faire reste que ce qu'ils aient arrêté
pris par le maire par exemple en ce qui
concerne la circulation et le
stationnement
et c'est la police nationale ou la
gendarmerie qui se charge du maintien de
la sécurité publique la mairie exerce
aussi des missions au nom de l'état mais
avec des moyens et du personnel
communaux il s'agit des missions de
l'état civil comme l'enregistrement des
naissances mariages et décès et
au nom de l'organisation des élections
municipales départementales régionales
législatives et présidentielle c'est
pourquoi l'on vote généralement dans les
écoles élémentaires
yat-il encore d'autre mission que doit
remplir une mairie bien entendu on peut
ajouter le ccas centre communal d'action
sociale dont le budget provient en
grande partie des subventions
municipales
le président du conseil d'administration
et paul bigard thouars mans le maire de
la commune et que représente la mairie à
la réunion à la réunion qui connaît un
taux de chômage de 30%
la mairie est un employeur important sur
son territoire via le personnel
titulaire et les contractuels en
particulier les nombreux emplois aidés
qui permettent d'assurer des services de
proximité comme l'entretien des espaces
verts
l'accompagnement scolaire en dehors des
heures de classe
l'animation périscolaire la mairie
assure aussi le service de restauration
scolaire et des crèches certaines
communes ou villes ont des mairies
annexes
à quoi sert-elle les mairies annexes ne
sont pas obligatoires mais les grandes
communes au nombre d'habitants où on sur
taf les mettre en place afin de
faciliter les démarches et se rapprocher
ainsi des citoyens
j'espère que vous avez compris ce qu'est
une mairie à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode